do you guys know there's porn online
apparently it's true they're both
freaking out looking the two of them
that's a totally shock I'll be back I'll
be back in a second gotta go check that
out I like him you were taking your
shirt off apparently all right well
according to
pornhub.com their number one porn star
is a 21 year old Lebanese girl named Mia
Khalifa we've got some pictures of Mia
there she is I think we've got one more
so she grew up in Lebanon but she moved
to the United States when she was a
teenager she now lives in Miami and
she's a student at Florida State
University but as her popularity from
her fine work has spread so to speak so
has a lot of hate coming up on her from
Lebanon and throughout the Arab world so
first up we're gonna start with some of
the the hate tweets that she's getting
okay so the first tweet you're seeing
here we did not blur that out this
person who tweeted that deleted their
account so this is a screen grab from
another website what they're saying
there is [ __ ] wonders why Arabs bash on
her maybe because you [ __ ] degraded
Muslims in a porno you five-cent ho the
next one you do realize that you'll be
the first person in hellfire right and
then third Mia Khalifa is a disgrace to
the Islam religion what a sick person
wears a hijab during a porno now what
they're referring to there is that right
there where she is wearing a hijab now
this type of stuff happens in porn all
the time I'm pretty sure there's a lot
of porn about nuns and teachers and all
kinds of I can corroborate you can write
Brett's confirming that for me now
interestingly Mia has been pretty
outspoken in her own defense so we've
got a couple tweets from her so this is
after someone created an image of what
appears to be an Isis fighter beheading
her she wrote congratulations
middle-east what the threats have
resorted to and obviously you can see
someone who's saying coming soon she
also does in the Middle East have more
important things to worry about besides
me how about finding a president or
containing Isis and someone tweeted at
her your head will be cut soon inshallah
long as it's not my tits they were
expensive so she's having some fun with
this she's defending herself again she
no longer lives in Lebanon she lives in
the United States so she's using her
freedom of speech anyway I don't point
this story I think is sort of that I
think that porn this is what could solve
the Middle East's problems if these
people wouldn't be so
sexually repressed yeah it would
actually help
is this a 748 years younger the religion
is that Christianity that like they just
haven't sure yeah mature into immaturity
yeah right now they're being very mature
right now they're being like we're
sticking to our rules in our guns and
this is what we do and we're not going
to give an inch it's a very teenage
response yeah now they need to get into
like oh I can I can masturbate it's fine
yeah no I'm not gonna kill anybody in in
fact it makes me feel better so actually
is that part of it because people always
say this that Christianity which is
older than Islam it went through its
really terrible period so this is only
the natural extension of religion sort
of what's happening right now the
natural progression of religion yeah I'd
be like you know what we all masturbate
Yeah right like to be really feel
fearful of it and then eventually be
like oh yeah it's a Catholicism till
today to get a cool Pope till right
before we started this show they you
know came ok yeah I mean we had never
really given that County but we had they
had really cool Pope's back in the day
they were like sleeping around and doing
all that stuff but they were also like
denying it and doing terrible things
yeah but like now you got some time now
that's all that's not to say that all
Muslims are like that of course it
cetera but like this this arm of it is
just so so insane you stop it but that I
look I think there would be if someone's
doing Jesus porn and for all those nun
porn things maybe not death threats but
definitely like Jesus porn
oh I'm sure there is I'm sure there's
but this is another rule of porn if you
ask the question is there blank point
the answer is already yes right and
that's sort of why I wanted to do this
segment on this show cuz we started with
the thing in France then we just talked
about Isis and this story it's this is
so obviously linked to me that if people
aren't free sexually and can get their
sexual [ __ ] out in an appropriate way
but then that's that's fertile ground I
think that's what Bill Maher says it's
fertile ground for extremism right yeah
absolutely
it's a nice fertile you like the fair
seriously though but joking aside this
girl is extremely brave don't you think
like as a female and as someone that's
public and putting her stuff out there I
mean at first it's always the first
person to do so
thing like this is going to see a lot of
resistance and a lot of danger and
thread and it's not fair to be like oh
she represents Muslims and she's
degraders she's one person and you know
what she's an American and I support
that no and she's the number-one person
and I think she's the number one person
on pornhub because I think someone
retired what yeah that was the things
like some was their real it was a
Christian porn star and it was like I
need to pass it on and now she's the
number one person on pornhub and she's
blown up like overnight
yeah she's gotten like like a day ago
she had 70,000 Twitter followers now she
has a hundred thousand by the time this
goes up who knows yeah but she's also
going to come stay with us when she
comes to Los Angeles she's tweeted it's
because we tweeted out or my girlfriend
and I said really yeah yeah definitely
she's gonna come hang out with us you
know any times you should come in that
sense yeah mihari times and once I did
not subconscious very upright on that
note Mia Khalifa I would love to have
you on the show so let us know
[Music]